hello boys and girls this is tim ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
tim ferriss show where it is my job to
deconstruct
world class performers interview people
from all different disciplines
to tease out the habits routines
favorite books etc that you can use my
guest
today is a madman dustin
yellen and you may not have heard this
name but by the end of this conversation
you'll definitely
look him up dustin yellen y-e-l-l-i-n
on instagram dustin yellen is an artist
who lives in brooklyn new york and is
the founder and director of pioneer
works
a multi-disciplinary cultural center in
red hook brooklyn that builds community
through the arts and sciences to create
an open and inspired
world it's a beautiful beautiful
facility so
if and when you can check it out i
highly recommend he and his incredible
work
have been featured by media and
organizations worldwide including the
new york times
art forum vanity fair and ted okay so
here we go the next paragraph
will make a lot more sense if you first
go to dustinyellen.com
and look at psychogeography or google
dustin
yellen psychogeography and look at the
images
that all having been said drawing on
both modernism and the sacred tradition
of hinterglass painting
yellen primarily works through a unique
form of three-dimensional photo montage
in which paint and images clipped from
various print media are embedded within
laminated glass sheets
to form grand picked graphic allegories
which dustin calls
frozen cinema but wait there's more
these totemic and kaleidoscopic works
often plumb the history and fate of
human consciousness within the
anthropocene
again that might not sound like it makes
any sense
but it makes a whole lot of sense if you
look for dustin yellen psycho
geography and we will do our best
to also include a photograph of one of
those at
tim.blog if you just search his name
dustin's art has been exhibited
at or with the amore pacific museum i'm
going to mispronounce a bunch of stuff
here
it could be amore pacific a-m-o-r-e
museum brooklyn museum
city museum collection collection solo
corning museum of glass the kennedy
center lincoln center for the performing
arts
museo del palacio de belas artes vegas
artes i'm not sure
scad or scad museum of art tacoma museum
and creative time
among many others he holds an honorary
doctor of humane letters degree from the
savannah college of art and design
you can find him again on instagram
dustinyellen
or at dustinyellen.com y-e-l-l-i-n
and also at pioneerworks.org please
enjoy
this incredible ride this roller coaster
through the mind and psyche and life
of dustin yellen
this episode is brought to you by xero
zero the world's most popular fasting
app
long-term listeners will know that i
take fasting very seriously i've studied
it
i've practiced it i do three-day fasts i
do seven
to ten day fasts every year and i take
it
super seriously the science i think is
in
there is increasingly more and more
literature pointing out the many
benefits
of doing even short periods of fasting
and now xero
is helping millions of users around the
world unlock healthier
longer lives by harnessing the power of
fasting it's been downloaded millions of
times like i mentioned
4.9 out of 5 stars on the apple app
store as an example with more than
200 000 ratings probably more than 300
000 ratings at this point
and up to this point in time for me
for years when i've had questions for
instance
do artificial sweeteners count can i
consume those even though perhaps they
might spike insulin levels a little bit
what about heavy cream and coffee if i
remain ketogenic
and i'm not adding any glucose to
my diet so to speak is that okay what
about the difference between say a 16
hour fast versus 72 hour versus
seven day what do we actually know how
much of this is just old wives tales
versus real science that we can point to
i would always call or text or email dr
peter attita
peter tia my friend he's been on the
podcast many times
and he is now zero's chief medical
officer so he has an entire library of q
as and questions
and advice all the kind of stuff that i
couldn't give anyone else access to
people now have access
to which is incredible so kevin rose my
buddy created this app initially in 2016
and
it's turned into an incredible community
and an incredible collection
of how-to and tracking capabilities so
whether you've been fasting for years or
just getting started xero equips you
with exclusive videos
from people like peter atia personalized
fasting plans and advanced health data
to keep you on track
listeners of this podcast that's you
guys can get 30
off a one year zero plus subscription
which gets you all sorts of goodies so i
would highly recommend checking it out
get a full
year's access to content and fasting
plans developed by the medical experts i
trust
like dr peter tia and save twenty
dollars just visit
xerofasting.com tim to get your
exclusive discount
that's zerofasting.com
tim and your discount will be
automatically applied
one last time zerofasting.com
tim
this episode is brought to you by
expressvpn i've been using expressvpn
since the summer of 2019.
it is a super simple and reliable way to
make sure that my data
are secure and encrypted without slowing
my internet speed so for instance i use
public wi-fi all over the place
might be at a starbucks it could be at a
restaurant sitting outside somewhere to
work i travel
all the time and expressvpn is an easy
way to make sure that i am not getting
my packets and data sniffed and
viewed by other people all you need to
do is download the expressvpn app on
your computer or smartphone and then use
the internet as you normally would
you click one button in the expressvpn
app to secure 100
of your network data of the many vpn
solutions out there
expressvpn is one of the best on the
market it's
super easy super simple and i use it
personally
in addition to protecting your data you
can also use a vpn to unlock movies and
shows that are only available in other
countries
so you can unlock content this is
actually a very very
good use case and super helpful
expressvpn hides your ip address and
lets you control
where you want sites to think you're
located you can choose from almost
100 different countries so just think
about all the netflix
libraries that you can go through if you
love anime use expressvpn to access
japanese netflix for instance and be
spirited away one of my favorite movies
by the way spirited away
but it's not just netflix expressvpn
works with any streaming service hulu
bbc iplayer youtube
you name it there's never any buffering
or lag and you can stream in
hd with no problem expressvpn is also
compatible with all of your devices
phones media consoles smart tvs and so
on so you can watch
what you want on the go or on a big
screen wherever you happen to be
so consider protecting yourself with the
vpn that i use and trust
visit expressvpn.com tim
and get an extra three months free on a
one year package
that's expressvpn.com
tim one more time check out
expressvpn.com
tim to learn more
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal questions
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
dustin welcome to the show thank you
very happy to be here
you are one of my favorite mad men i've
been following ever since we first
met at pioneer works and was blown away
by your art blown away by
your storytelling i remember this family
going with
my crazy bulgarian assistant slash
director of editorial with you on a
little tour of your studio
and it seemed like your life story was
just the most incredible eclectic mix of
things and i thought we would start
and we're going to go down all sorts of
roads but let's start with
you dropping out of high school and my
understanding is that you end up
hitchhiking around new zealand and i was
curious how
that came to be well i actually don't
remember
i was in colorado i dropped out of high
school i i for some reason
couldn't connect to
the system of education and i just
wanted out so
i tried to persevere and then i left and
i
i turned 18 and i had
a bet with my mom where if i didn't do
any
drugs or alcohol or smoke cigarettes or
anything until i was 18
i would win this bet and uh she was
gonna give me a car basically but when i
was 16 i
like hustled swatch watches actually and
i made some money
on my own and bought my own car so when
i turned 18 i said look i won the bet
but i already have a car that i paid for
with my own money so
you know you're gonna have to give me
some cash which i then
spent on drugs sex and rock and roll and
just went bananas
copious amounts of hallucinogens at a
very at 18 which is maybe good because a
lot of these kids
you know don't know what they're doing
and they're 12. so so it was cool
and and then i just decided to get out
of colorado kind of picked a map and
went
to new zealand and just started
hitchhiking and through australia
uh hitchhiking as well and i hadn't
been very cultured as a kid and so
i was like a late bloomer and at 18
here i am on lsd for the first time
listening to
led zeppelin and pink floyd and having
my own sort of
woodstock in my my mind as i'm
hitchhiking through these countries
and it was pretty crazy and getting
exposed to all this weird stuff through
people i met on the road
and then i ended up in thailand on an
island on lots of mushrooms they'd put
them in your omelets
and i was like this is paradise i'll
never leave
why would i ever go back to what i knew
before i'm just gonna
live on this island and then that kind
of at some point scared me because
i was like whoa i'm so detached from
what i once knew and then i went back to
colorado
and met that crazy physicist
so we we're okay we're gonna get to the
crazy physicist i want to leave that
just as a cliffhanger for folks for a
second
let's go back to the swatch watches for
a minute when doing homework
for this it seems like you had the
hustle from a very
young age and i read that you
used to busk as a breakdancer
i don't know if it was on the venice
boardwalk or somewhere but as a little
kid you take this boom box out
and flash forward you're i mean
honestly your bio is just hilariously
fascinating and almost unbelievable to
me at some point later
30 years later you end up somehow break
dancing in jay-z's 2013 picasso baby
video
i i mean i it's hard for me to even
connect these but where does the hustle
come from the entrepreneurial
hustle that i think has served you well
in
a whole lot of different areas you know
i i don't know
where it comes from i think perhaps it
was always there
i have no idea i guess it's in my dna i
don't know
do your parents or any siblings have
similar
programming that type of entrepreneurial
yeah i think make something from nothing
both my parents have a bit of that and
i've had it
i guess i mean and and you know my mom
left my pa when i was five
and took me to telluride colorado and
she's a single mom at that point
always on the road working and hustling
herself so i kind of raised myself
since i was five it feels like and
so there was a lot of just having to
figure it out
whatever a b i think
was your mom supportive of your various
i don't want to call them schemes but
the various money-making operations
from it seems like a really early age
you should know about them
yeah yeah my mom was always very
supportive she was
very not around i think in in my youth
but also very supportive of my
whatever it may be you know i think
everyone got a little bit more nervous
when i
kind of dropped out of high school and
then when i turned 18
and got pretty pretty wild in
and and then made then of course i think
my father was completely horrified
and my mother was just praying i would
get through it so let's segue back to
physicists so how do you meet this
physicist
and who is this person you know
just very unusual circumstances i
returned from thailand
to colorado and uh this woman
that i was very fond of and dated
uh introduced me to
or she started telling me about this
physicist and that he was
brilliant and that he was working on
environmental sciences and the damage
from the gulf war
and and was trying to make free energy
like nikola tesla and of course
i didn't know who nikola tesla was at
the time so i'm now learning
who that is and and that he worked with
buckminster fuller and i didn't know who
that was and started learning about
bucky fuller and
so again getting introduced to all this
new stuff
and i told her i wanted to meet him and
i met him
and you know he was maybe the first
adult to turn me on to
cultural lighthouses like pablo neruda
or dostoyevsky or you know
tesla all these different things and
reading and music and kind of just
teaching me and i was obsessed so i
asked him if i could
study with him and he
kind of tried to discourage me not to
because he said that that would be
dangerous because the government you
know
was watching him because he was trying
to make free energy so
he was he was really really out there
and also really really brilliant and
that made me really really interested
to learn from him he finally accepted
me to learn from him and we would have
just conversations and
and do mushrooms and lsd together and
just have these long
conversations and then he
basically he was like putting me into a
closet
on a saline solution bed with a quartz
crystal on my chest listening to whales
and he was like look you're gonna think
i
killed you you're gonna think you're
dead you're gonna think
i'm a pathological murderer and that
i've killed you don't you worry it'll
pass
and he would inject me with ketamine
and i didn't know this is straight up
altered states
it was a great movie and kind of got
messed up
the second half because it got sort of
obsessed with primordial regression
opposed to progression
but william hurt did a great job in that
picture um and that was i guess loosely
based on john lily's life
and and john john knew the scientists
that i was working with and
and i'm having like so i'm having these
crazy
out of body experiences where i'm
leaving my body
uh in this sort of you know pure
consciousness
state and i'm becoming one cell
in my arm and then i'm one star and then
i'm
um you know fractalized into billions of
little pieces
recombobulating and then the more i
would do it i could navigate
through what i guess i perceived to be
consciousness
and i had all these crazy visions which
i felt like
kind of is what sent me to new york
how so how did those send it to new york
well
you know this like blew my mind because
i'm making these crazy paintings
i'm making art constantly at this point
when did that start sorry to interrupt
but when did the
artwork start well i mean i always made
weird [ __ ]
but i never really thought about it as
anything you know i would make
little drawings or i'd make things out
of rocks and sticks and things i found
in the in the forest which i
actually i i've been doing all week this
week so nothing's really changed in
in a long time um so i guess i was
always doing that but by the time i was
17 or so i was like this is what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna make art
and i didn't really know about art
history yet i mean i might have known
who andy warhol is or picasso or matisse
but i really knew nothing
and but art felt like the greatest
freedom
because it felt like something you could
it was completely free you could invent
whatever
and you were never limited to the thing
you invented because you could go and
invent something else
and then after i met the physicist i
became obsessed with the sciences
because i was like holy [ __ ] this whole
world is a hallucination everything's
been invented
therefore we can just build some crazy
utopic vision of what we think
it should look like on this planet and
so
the arts the art became almost like the
voice
and the science became like the
tactic or something i don't know yeah i
think so i mean i think that are you
saying the art was sort of the
the inspiration or the muse and the
science was the
sort of means by which you expressed
whatever had been
kind of intuited or received by you is
that what you mean
yeah and i think i was really obsessed
with clean energy in like the 60s even
though
we were in the 90s i was you know
getting obsessed with nikola tesla and i
was getting obsessed with this idea of
of
that we could make clean and free energy
and therefore
i felt like the art was almost the
bonfire
you know which you could get people
around and if you could get everybody
around a fire
then you could start to build these more
complex systems
which could be scaling clean energy or
you know
various new forms of uh political
systems
now you you said that some of the
visions are experiences
when you're in these saline baths right
so people can imagine if you float in
the dead sea because of the the high
salt content that's like half your body
is kind of suspended
i wasn't actually in the baths like like
john lily i was
i was on a sailing solution bed in a
dark room oh i see all right that's a
lot safer okay
feeling but a lot safer precisely yeah
now during those experiences you said
some of what was imparted or experienced
led you to new york how is that
well i think i was feeding if you will
these enormous delusions of grandeur
where i'm like everything is possible
do you know what i mean like i could do
anything and
i'm in a small town in colorado and i'm
obsessed now with you know i'm like i'm
going to make
art and i'm going to that's what's going
to be my medium is making things out of
nothing and so
i basically reduced the idea that the
only way to do that was to go to new
york city
that's where the artists were it felt
like you know that's where that's where
people were
because i was in a small town and the
kids were like drinking beer
on the mountainside talking about hockey
and i was like i need to get the [ __ ]
out of here
and how did you then find your way or
fund your
way both i guess at that time to
new york right how are you making ends
meet i went there
without really knowing anyone or or
anything and found a uh
you know and my mom was very generous
and she said look i'll help you
with putting like a very cheap roof over
your head
and then you need to figure it out so i
went there
and found like i basically rented
through i think it was like craigslist
or the village voice i found a room it
was more like a closet
from some dude in soho and i
lived in this little tiny room and he
was very generous and gave me another
room to make paintings in
and again i was young and wild and uh i
was just making these
crazy abex i didn't even know what
abec's abstract expressionism probably
was at the time but looking back i was
making these weird abex paintings
and renting this little closet room from
the sky
and out every night like a wild man
and somehow talked my way into these
bars and places at the time it was a
place called the bowery bar
and a place called spy and i i don't
know
i was very lucky because i met all these
amazing people
right off the boat so to speak that a
lot of them are still in my life today
so yeah i don't know how that happened i
just i met people
right away yeah well i mean it sounds
like you went to the action
and then you sort of entered yourself as
one of the lottery balls in that
spinning container of a thousand other
lottery balls and
bumped into a lot which would be viewed
as serendipity but you kind of
engineered it by going
to the center of the action what year
roughly
do you recall when you got to new york
94 i think
94. all right and
when did you first feel like and maybe
you felt this all along
but from the standpoint of keeping you
afloat financially
when was the first inkling that you felt
art could do that for you
well in my mind coming to new york i
thought oh
of course it would be so easy once i got
to new york that wasn't the case
and talk about hustle i mean i'd be like
buy this painting for me two thousand
two thousand dollars no no buy the
painting thousand dollars thousand
dollars
bucks buy that painting i get to eat
some food come on you know
i was crazy and then and then i'd be
like if
someone didn't want the painting i'd be
like just take it like
just take it because i thought to myself
well if they take it and they hang it on
their wall
and 20 people see it and 19 of them
can't
not stand it but one person likes it
and asks about it maybe then maybe you
know it would become a plague
did you say a plague yeah yeah yeah
because it's like a plague it's like a
disease art you know
if i could get you know really one
person
if if you put something in a room and 50
people don't like it but the 51st person
loves it and wants one
and they get it and then they do the
same thing and the next 50 people don't
like it but
one person sees it and they get one over
a lot of time
that can really you know get you going
and that's what i would do i would just
hustle
i was wild i'd be doing [ __ ] what do
you call them like
cartwheels and somersaults through the
bar and i had like long hair and beards
and beads
and like i was you know what i mean i
was i was out there i was meeting people
who were also teaching me like that's
where i got
my education really was from the people
i was meeting
how many pieces of artwork would you
guess you
gave away for free or close to free
dozens
hundreds a handful i don't know multiple
dozens
yeah i don't know maybe 50 100 who knows
i mean
and some of that stuff will like appear
nowadays or someone will call me out of
the boom be like i have this painting
from 95 and i'm like can you [ __ ]
burn it you know
good on them for holding on to it so
so 94.95 i've thought about actually
this is from a conversation i had with a
friend named graham duncan
when he was on this podcast he talked
about
swimming in this metaphorical river and
on one hand
you have kind of hyper regen on one
shore one side you have this like hyper
rigidity
ocd etc and on the other side you
have chaos and
serendipity and psychosis right you have
these two extremes and you can swim down
the middle you can swim to either side
and sometimes
people get like lodged on one of those
shores
this is leading to a question about
zelda i don't know if this question is
going to make any sense
but who was zelda and why did you have
to rescue her
does this question make any sense if not
i can
so i was obsessed with f scott
fitzgerald
and and then of course zelda fitzgerald
and yeah and and so for some reason i i
was having
what one could call a mild psychotic
break
and i had this moment
where i
thought that everyone
knew each other that everyone was almost
playing a joke on each other that they
didn't know each other
almost this idea of the seven daughters
of eve where we all came from
the same mother but now there's billions
of us
and i and then i thought everyone was
pretending not to know so i would walk
by a restaurant and i would wave at
everybody
thinking like hey everybody and they
would all look at me weird and
it was really weird and i was adding up
things so
like if i saw you tim i'd be like tim uh
t equals 20 uh i i
is whatever it is m is 13 and i'd add up
your name and i thought there was this
like
numerical meaning and and i
i was filming all this because i had
traded a drawing for a little
handycam i think that's what they were
called the cameras so i was filming
everything by myself just whatever i was
doing
and i had this moment where i was
writing all over my paintings
i thought everybody knew each other and
i went
on to a boat there's a great have you
seen the video the crack up
no i haven't seen the video i just read
about it there's this video where i
accidentally filmed a psychotic break
and i go on to the forbes boat
and i'm like this is my boat and the
guy's like what are you talking about
i'm like this is my boat and i kind of
thought like this is my world
and he was like what are you talking
about are you
related to the forbes family and i was
like yes
directly f-o-r-b-e-s
and he kind of he listened for a little
while and he gave me a tour of the boat
until he realized i'm
i was bananas and then he kicked me off
the boat
and then i this was a like on chelsea
piers and then i walked over to the
chelsea piers
or golf range where they hit the balls
you know and i literally just
in the night time by myself filming
walked onto the field and started
kicking the golf balls
and walked up to the guy driving the
vehicle
used to pick up the balls and i said to
him and i used the wrong
words because i said i need to reprimand
your vehicle
you're trying to say requisition i guess
totally
the guy was like are you crazy i'm like
no no you don't understand
i'm having a party on this field and
i need this vehicle and so jump on the
back and so he literally
held the camera jumped in the back onto
the balls and i started driving and i
tried to drive the vehicle out
into the outside of this area and
of course he grabbed the keys and
brought out the managers
and i tried to convince them they
weren't having it and so i left
and then the very next morning i went
into central park
under the same idea that everyone knew
each other
and i never forgot because i was talking
to everyone as if they were family and i
started talking to this guy and having a
long conversation in the park
and then my mem if my memory serves me
right he tried to kiss me
and that freaked me out and i ran
so now i'm like running through the park
and
i go to belvedere castle i don't even
know if i knew what belvedere castle was
but i go to the castle in the park
and i climbed it and i scaled the castle
and the police came and
got me down from the castle and they
were so nice they were like what are you
doing
up there and for 15 minutes the police
were really nice they were like
trying to and i was like i'm i've got to
sit i'm looking for love and they were
trying to understand what love was i'm
like
i have you know and i was demanding that
they opened up this castle because there
were classrooms in there
to let the kids use the frogs and the
dinosaurs and the microscopes
and the police and i had a very nice
15-minute conversation where they were
really trying to understand my
motivations
and finally after 15 minutes they were
like you're under arrest they threw me
on the ground i peed in my pants
they took my book which was uh f scott
fitzgerald's
the crack up which was like a
book from 1945 published on new
directions of essays
that edmund wilson has editor put
together and they took my book
they put me in central park prison i'll
never forget they took my shoelaces
then the ambulance came took me to a
hospital my
my two best friends who are both no
longer with us
came to try to get us out get me out and
i wouldn't leave the hospital
because i was in this weird narrative
that this is where i was supposed to be
and my friends are like we're going i'm
like no
and literally there i'm arguing with my
best friends and they were like get
out let's go and then for some reason i
wouldn't leave
then another ambulance took me to a full
lockdown
i'm writing all over the walls like my
numeric
codes and finally you know it's like the
whole thing in the movies with the glass
and the little pill cups and
finally i was like okay i'm ready to
leave and they were like you cannot
leave
and i was like no i'm ready to go you're
like no
and my parents who had not been on an
airplane together
in i don't know how long got to get flew
from the west coast
and they got me out
it was amazing so all right so amazing
is definitely one
one word there there are many
descriptors one could use that
video to crack up and then it makes
sense
well i'll check out the video to those
listening
i suppose a few at least would think to
themselves
holy [ __ ] god that is terrifying
two questions for you number one is was
that
out of left field psychotic break was it
precipitated by something
so that's number one and number two is
have you ever gone so far to the shore
of chaos
and psychosis that you've scared
yourself
hmm good question uh i don't know what
was the
cause of this i think i mean one could
it was a long time ago so one could
point to a surplus of hallucinogens
one could one could also just say like
oh wow
i was having such a fin like life was so
good it was a dream
and i got so enmeshed into the dream
that the dream sort of interconnected us
all and even at the time i don't think
it scared me because i was
i thought it was real and since then
i mean sure i've probably scared myself
a few times but
not so bad i think it's good to shake it
up a little so you've never been worried
about
losing your tether to this reality
and really just ending up in a
psych ward for years or decades you've
never had that concern
no why is that
no idea i mean i just
i just never i was never there you know
how people
are manic depressive is something that
one can be
one say that i'm just manic
i see i've provided a great fertile soil
to make
work
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront did you know
if you missed 10 of the best performing
days after the 2008 crisis you would
have missed out on fifty percent
five zero percent of your returns don't
miss out on the best days in the market
stay invested in a long-term automated
investment portfolio wealthfront
pioneered the automated investing
movement sometimes referred to as robo
advising
and they currently oversee 20 billion
dollars of assets for their clients
wealthfront can help you diversify your
portfolio minimize fees and lower your
taxes
it takes about three minutes to sign up
and then wealthfront will build you a
globally diversified portfolio of etfs
based on your risk appetite and manage
it for you
at an incredibly low cost wealthfront
software constantly monitors your
portfolio day in and day out so you
don't have to
they look for opportunities to rebalance
and tax loss harvest to lower the amount
of taxes you pay on your investment
gains
their newest service is called autopilot
and it can monitor any checking account
for excess cash to move into savings or
an investment account
they've really thought of a ton they've
checked a lot of boxes
smart investing should not feel like a
roller coaster ride let the
professionals do the work for you
go to wealthfront.com tim and open a
wealthfront investment account today
and you'll get your first five thousand
dollars managed for free for life that's
wealthfront.comtim
wealthfront will automate your
investments for the long term and you
can get started today at wealthfront.com
tim
you told another story i recall
during this first tour of your studio
where i was marveling at your work which
which people have to
look up and certainly visit your
instagram account
which is just at dustin yellen but
there's this family
or a mom and dad and their son and i
remember you ended up we were all
standing in a circle at one point
and you're telling this story that
completely captivated and mesmerized i
want to say this like 12 year old boy
and the parents were just not sure what
to make of it and i thought the whole
thing was hilarious because you're
telling a story about
i want to say lsd and swimming from one
place to another or i can't recall
exactly but does that ring any bell at
all
something involving swimming and
hallucinogens oh let me think
i mean if not it's okay it's probably
one of a hundred stories i just remember
more
the audience reaction and the facial
expressions more than anything else
well i i don't know i mean i definitely
i've come
closest to death swimming once to a bird
sanctuary
i was swimming to a bird sanctuary and
then i
also in the bocas in panama
i was spearfishing for hamlets and we
were on a beach with a few
scientists and i got swept away i was
told not to swim i should have listened
but i don't think i was on any
hallucinogens either time
so i don't recall almost drowning
because of hallucinogens but i have
definitely almost drowned
okay that's perfectly
good as a way of getting to the question
which is
how did you develop your
abilities as a storyteller or maybe a
better question
is because that's always a tricky one
like what makes
a good storyteller right i know you you
seem to be a fan
of werner herzog there are certainly
others but like
you are a good storyteller in your mind
what makes a good storyteller and are
there any people who stick out
as really good storytellers oh well
there's so many i wouldn't even know
where to start
verner is an amazing storyteller i mean
f scott fitzgerald murakami i wouldn't
even know where to start with
storytellers
there's so many but i think perhaps
being
curious is a great place to start and
trying to be fearless is another place
where you just want to
inject the entire
civilization into your neural networks
as fast as possible all of the time so
whenever you're
conscious there's more than you could
possibly
input i mean even right now while i'm
speaking to you i'm looking at a
mountain
i'm looking at hundreds probably
thousands of trees
i know that there's a river about a
hundred yards in front of me in a valley
even though i can't see it i've been on
that river every day looking for rocks
there's just so you know the infinite
detail
in our existence is so vast that if you
can be aware of it and process it then
somehow you might be able to describe it
and then that could become a captivating
story and if you put yourself
in those places
often it becomes a great
medium i guess so i'm constantly
throwing myself into the depths of the
amazon or papua new guinea or africa or
all kinds of weird places always like
i'm kind of a bit of an explorer
and then the things you see and the
things you experience
you describe and i think that people are
like planets
as well so you could say the same thing
for a person right and all of their
experiences that
you could describe if you think about
you know any anybody a musician a writer
a data scientist
i don't know if that answers the
question yeah it's kind of secondary
if what you say answers the question i
think if it's important i'll
i'll come back to it it's more of a
prompt what i say i'm just kind of like
a
you know buzz lightyear pole doll that's
trying to keep things moving in certain
directions or any direction but the
observation that you made about
sort of the detail of reality
makes me think of aldous huxley in doors
of perception talking about
the mind as a reducing valve right
in so much as we're optimized to fight
fornicate
flee basically and that
on some level you can imagine
hallucinogens
allowing dropping or widening the
aperture of your reducing valve so that
you're
you're seeing a lot of what is it that's
amazing literally just said what i
always say i even said it to to someone
this
yesterday i say it almost every 72 hours
which is
if i'm speaking about hallucinogens i
say exactly that it's literally imagine
your aperture is opening up
and therefore more light
more color more sound is coming in have
you found anything
outside of hallucinogens to help you to
widen the aperture so that you can
absolutely i mean when i'm drawing you
know people have been trying to get me
to meditate
and i think i've done it but not in a
traditional sense and and a
lot of folks would say meditation will
take you very much to the same place
nature i mean just you know i've been
out here
hiking every day in the river i think
being conscious for take the
hallucinogens out of it completely
but somehow just being conscious of of
where
you are in the world and what you are in
the world and the
complete incomprehensible
mysticism that is inherent
in the very fact that you can
experience or be conscious of any
experience
is the same as potentially
you know intaking in a hallucinogen for
those
folks listening and i i wonder this too
who are saying to themselves this guy's
fascinating his stories
are incredible and i have no
idea whatsoever how he is not
self-destructed like how he has managed
his life or had it managed in such a way
that he's become
a super successful artist what would you
say to them is it
just a miracle that you've had like
you've kind of
rolled snake eyes a thousand times or is
there more to it
well i think i don't know is what i
would say i would say yes i've been
extraordinary lucky lucky lucky every
day i'm like just don't die this [ __ ] is
so good don't die
don't die [ __ ] get one more day
in there um
so
i've been very lucky and i'm very
grateful for that i think i'm also very
cautious you know i'm not doing lots of
hard drugs i'm not
you know as i've gotten older i'm slower
to jump in a
crazy wild ocean if i don't know that i
could actually swim in it
or into a river if i think that it's
going to take me down
so i've been very lucky but i also think
yeah i think you can dive into the
infinite
complexity of our existence
and and not and do that by not just
rolling snake eyes every time but by
just
being open and curious which is i think
the great way for how people learn is by
just being curious
i totally agree and i'm going to dig a
little bit more
well i'm going to dig a lot more just
because part of what i try to do in
these conversations is to
tease out the some people don't like
this term but like the superpowers are
idiosyncrasies that
allow people to break the normal molds
of society and achieve
unusual things right which you have done
demonstrably
objectively you have done that one thing
that came up as i was reading
were quotes describing you as
anti-competitive
and i'm wondering if if maybe that's a
gingerbread trail
worth following and thinking about and
i'm looking at
this quote from a vanity fair piece from
2015
and this comes up a few times elsewhere
also
but it mentions a friend of yours is it
tom rice i don't know if i'm pronouncing
that correctly but um
he's winning amazing yeah you got to
meet him
i'd love to meet him and he and his
quote is dustin loves everyone else's
creative egos
he's learned the magic formula which is
that if you're competing with other
creative people you're just depleting
your energy and destroying yourself
that's really interesting can you
comment on that i don't know if it's
accurate if you consider it accurate but
can you speak to that
well sure i mean i'm obs
i think that that that the species is
pretty incredible
and i just the way i'm
uh inspired by nature constantly i'm
inspired by people and people are part
of nature
and so when i fall in love with
well like tom's books is a great example
and tom
is a great example but you know you
could go just down the list
and line of incredible souls making
amazing
drawings and paintings and movies and
records and math problems and all of it
all of that stuff to me is is [ __ ]
amazing
incredible
magnetic material that can help
propel you through the world so
i just want to get turned on more and
more and more to
all the cool potential that can be
unleashed by
uh certain combinations of
i don't know if it's neural activity or
if it's you know
meta [ __ ] cloud stimulation
yeah what form if it's the right term
does anti-competitiveness
take like what does that look like to be
anti-competitive
in the art world well i think it's to
embrace
and love your community and to help
your community realize their dreams not
just your dreams
and if you could make your dreams part
of
dreaming that how do we help realize
everybody's dreams together in some
collective orgy of dreams
now is that driven by optimism and
idealism is it driven
in part by just finding that a better
way to increase your energy as opposed
to deplete it
what led you to that i don't know if
there's anything great
specific uh schism that that led me
there
you know except that sort of corny silly
idea that there's like love and fear
like we can all love each other or we
can all fear each other
and it seems so simple like we can all
come together and say look we're gonna
figure out how to be stewards to this
planet together
and create great clean technologies and
great responsible ways
for eight or 10 billion people to live
together or we could
you know create conflict and i guess
competition
and territorialism and i feel like
the idea of a country which is kind of
arbitrary and new
and religions and sort of different ways
in which we
draw lines around thought and
can maybe create ceilings for us so but
for me it's a very much
i would have guessed a natural natural
state that we should just all love each
other and build
the world that we want to inhabit
because the entire thing is just
malleable and sculptable and
you know i have another quote that i'd
love to
fact check see if it's accurate first of
all but second just to hear you
explain it if it makes any sense because
it stuck out for me and that is
from a new york times piece
and the quote is i don't worry about
inspiration as much as system overload
i don't know if you remember saying that
if you did but what does that mean
i feel that every day tim oh
well what does that mean i feel it every
[ __ ] day i feel it red now
uh i'll give you an example i'm making
sculptures right now out of rocks
and i love rocks and i go up the valley
and i go on to a river where there's i
guess probably millions of little rocks
and as i'm looking for the rocks
in the hot sun with my head sort of
gazed down at the ground
i say to myself holy [ __ ]
there are so many rocks how could i
possibly see them all
at the same time and
then distinguish which ones will fit
together
in order to make something out of them
and i could say the same thing about
people or places or pretty much
anything that there's just so much if i
said to you i'm just gonna read poetry
[ __ ] i'm just gonna read japanese poets
for the rest of my life
that in itself would i could spend 100
years doing
just that or just watching french films
or just
you know learning about
specific plants uh
there's so much to learn and to be
exposed
to and to remember if which which i have
a very hard time doing
that constantly i'm in system overload
and
so when someone i you know i always get
that question well what inspires you
you know like oh what pain or what that
i'm like [ __ ] man i'm inspired by
by everything i'm inspired by being
conscious right now the fact that we can
have this conversation that's a [ __ ]
miracle
and really it is and then
so but if you play that out and you like
are
kind of trying to till the soil to be
aware or as we said earlier open our
apertures and the more and more you open
your apertures the more and more you
possibly maybe perceive
and you know huxley's a great example an
amazing amazing brain um
then how do you mitigate system overload
and so where my challenges have been i
think is that
i'm always trying to widen that aperture
and then at the same time i'm like oh
but i should have some kids and wouldn't
it be nice to
like do things that happen in the world
that maybe require a little closing of
the aperture or something or something
to focus because it feels like
just this endless infinite
awesome sea of possibility
that is always where you are what have
you
found to help
if anything with system overload because
for
you as someone who fuels the world
deeply
and who willingly wants to widen and
maintain the width of your aperture this
is just an
ongoing in a sense like an onslaught of
input
so what do you do what are what are some
of the things that you found to be
helpful for
preventing complete overwhelm i like to
draw and i like to
be in the middle of nowhere and i like
to smoke marijuana no
i mean
i like uh i like to uh
those three things i like a lot love to
make love
uh there's a lot of things i think that
could help one
to uh yeah like somebody got me to
meditate on a lake this week that was
pretty cool
um swimming can be good i guess oh yeah
watching you know things like
i can watch a movie and it puts me in a
world
which then makes it so that i'm kind of
living that world while
watching it and therefore i'm not
thinking about the ten
zillion other possible things i could be
watching
you seem to have watched
a lot of film do you have any favorite
films or for people who don't know
anything about film if they're like
dustin
please guide me through the light or the
darkness or however you want to do it
please
can you make some recommendations do you
have any any films that come to mind
that are films you've
recommended a lot or watched over and
over again
yeah i often recommend a movie called
fitzgeraldo
by werner herzog um
i highly recommend that and many of
werner's movies
um there's a great movie that's really
funny i don't know if you've seen this
movie tim called bad boy bubby
no i have not i like the title though
australian movie 1993
i believe bad boy bubby that's a cool
movie another movie
called the color of pomegranates i i can
never say his name perhajn
it's he's an armenian director um
you know i love hal ashby's being there
he also made herald and mod um
i mean jesus movies there's you know
claude cabral is a great french director
um you know obviously kubrick
watch all of kubrick's movies and
tarkovsky's movies
and tarkovsky wrote a great book about
filmmaking called sculpting
in time yeah sculpting in time
let's grab one of them so you mentioned
fitzgeraldo
first why do you recommend that movie
to people what is it about it not only
that movie but
the there's a great documentary about
the making of the movie called burden of
dreams
of dreams yeah by les blanc but
fitzgeraldo i mean
it's just this ultimate metaphor of this
human who wants to bring
the opera into the depths of the amazon
and the sort of trials and tribulations
of what that means
and in the course of the film they to
get out of the
jungle they have to carry a boat over
a mountain which i think is just a great
metaphor for what it's like
to be alive well it sounds
also a lot like
building pioneer works
can you can you just describe how did
pioneer works for people who don't
have any idea no visual in their mind of
what pioneer works
is maybe you could just tell describe
what it is
and then describe what it was because i
i've visited in person
and it's spectacular but
that is not how things began can you
describe it for people
what it is now or yeah what it is now
and then rewind
and talk about what you can do neither
or what what it was and what it is now
or what it is now and what it was
however you want to approach it
well i mean i think it was just a
hallucination and a dream
and it's genesis i think is no
it's no i don't i don't think it was
like this great idea that
i think every kid in every art school
probably had
similar sentiments of like why isn't
there a place where i can go
where there's writers and scientists and
artists and musicians and filmmakers all
together
in a building sharing ideas thinking
together
and and dreaming together like why i
wasn't and i
again didn't go to high school i didn't
go to college and
so maybe subliminally or sublimely or
somehow this was a way for me to
incarnate what i wished to be
or wish to experience at some point but
but i didn't i never understood why
isn't there a place where just
everybody's that together
trying to think about how we build this
world together
so it started very much as is a
is just an obvious question i guess like
why why doesn't this exist
and when i was younger you know i
started having
you know roommates and i'd have a loft
with lots of people playing music and
reading poetry and kind of together
and i sort of had these primitive
versions of this
naturally but i guess so so
what is pioneer works now it's it's an
institute
with a mission and i don't know if
institute's the right word but its
mission is to
build community through the arts and
sciences to create an
open and inspired world so what does
that mean i mean i mean it's basically
like how do we use
arts and sciences to bring people
together to build the world they want to
live in
and uh now it's you know somewhere
between a school and the
learning center and a museum and a
community center and
and i don't know what it's it's uh it's
a social experiment
that i think could end up being a great
model as a learning center and i don't
like to use the word school because it
feels
like it puts you in something that is
old
and not necessarily functioning in its
current state so
so i'd say it's a learning center a
cultural center when i say culture i
have to
circle sciences because a lot of folks
don't think about science as part of
culture well how large is it
my subjective experience was feeling
that it was vast
when i walked through and walked through
again and then had two glasses of wine
and walked through again
how big is this space it's so funny
because when i
got the building it was uh
an ironworks built at the end of the
civil war
and i had to beg everybody around me
i couldn't afford the building and i was
begging everyone and collectors were
like look here's a half a million
dollars
you know get the building and we'll take
the art later just i was begging
everybody and i almost it almost didn't
happen and when i first went in the
building i was like this thing is
giant like you're saying and and it's
about 27 000 square feet inside and
about 20 000 square feet outside
at its current footprint where we're
we're going to be adding some things
and it felt massive now it feels
absolutely tiny
now i walk in there i'm like [ __ ] we
have no
room we need five more classrooms we
need to
triple the size of the tech department
the science area needs to be twice the
size
you know we we need to build recording
studios we have a tiny
recording studio but but it's not big
enough we need you know
we need a place for a democracy and
equality
uh program which is going to require 10
people in the narrative arts program
which
you know so every right now it's it's uh
yes it's it doesn't you know we we do
about 75 residencies a year where we're
giving space for free to scientists and
artists and writers etc
uh so we need more more place for the
residents so
i don't know if that it feels tiny let's
let's go back to
as i've read you describe it uh the
original [ __ ]
no windows no floors no stairs no
utilities
uh and you're trying to gather millions
of dollars
that's a hard pitch it would seem and
so what worked what got the money what
what what was the pitch
what what personal parents was you can
persevere and bang your head against the
wall
with a shitty pitch and it will not work
but it did work so
what happened and why did it work
well i would say a few different things
you know in the beginning
i was or for a very long time even in
the beginning
uh i was i was just giving away all my
money so if i sold a sculpture
like and i would beg you i'd be like you
want to buy a piece of art you're
disgusting capitalist pig i'm not
selling you any art
help us do this thing people don't need
objects
people need ideas
how close how close to verbatim was that
i mean would you actually
was that the sentiment or would you
actually say that and just endear
yourself because you gave zero [ __ ]
no i'd say it but sweetly and somewhat
ironically
um and i believed it i was like look if
you could buy a piece of art from me for
a couple hundred thousand dollars well
then you could help us with this bigger
dream which is
not about me or my art but about a lot
of people
and and so for years i did that i if
someone wanted
to buy my art i'd be like look i'm glad
you like this art but
look at this crazy project we're
building and and i gave away
everything i mean i almost bankrupted my
art studio
every few months because i was just
keeping it going barely and then you
know
water heaters stairs floors
roof repair whatever it took to get the
building inhabitable
so that was like the first stage was
just like can we get this building
safe and i thought that would take a
decade let me pause for one second so
you said giving
stuff away so that they you have on one
hand the
well-funded capitalist pigs as you put
it right i guess uh
you know yes
like merchant class right or like
merchant or aristocracy
then you have everybody else who are you
giving your art away to
during that period of time and why are
you giving it away no
no i'm not i'm selling the art to people
but like let's say a collector comes in
the studio and this happened
i'm like oh you're giving you mean the
proceeds of that back to pioneers
yeah mike please buy this sculpture
because we will get
water heaters yep i see i see you
buy this piece of art and we might get
some windows
got it and so i would say in the
beginning that helped jumpstart
the project and then you know somebody
was like you need to start a non-profit
i didn't know what that was and the
board of director you know
and and i would say at its very best
what pioneer works is now and maybe
always
was and will be is an amalgam of souls
it's a group of people it's like you
know gabriel florence the artistic
director
who's you know like my brother and jana
levin who who i know you know who's like
my sister
and you know family and like all these
incredible
people who you know you know what i used
to say and i used to think of
it and i still do is is pioneer works is
just a table
it's just a table and it's like
whoever's at the [ __ ] table
is is making it work i like that that's
really
a beautiful metaphor and visual
how do you and maybe the answer is
somebody else doesn't i have no idea but
you strike well you don't strike me you
are a
manic artist and
you love making art how do you
balance that with the managerial
responsibilities does it drive you
[ __ ] nuts
to do that kind of stuff or is there
some way you think about it
how do you integrate that if you do well
i would say that
a couple of different ways one
i'm lucky i mean the last decade has
been really challenging to do both
but i try not to think of it as both so
i think of pioneer works as a social
sculpture i just think of it as another
artwork and i think and the way i try to
measure some of the success of that
artwork
is that my obsolescence is my success
so the sooner that i can be obsolete and
the thing works really really well
then i know i've done my job and here we
are a decade later
and i think there's some some truth
where i can kick it
and this thing is going to flourish 36
months ago that would not have happened
so i would say that me not being there
and it working really well is success
and i think of it as an artwork
that's helped me to do it for so long
i will say it's i'm at a new place with
it because we're
pw's really working well now and there's
incredible brain trust and group
involved that it's working and i'd say
that i
i mean it wasn't tenable but by the
seventh year in or eighth year in i mean
i was giving tours five six seven tours
a day and you know people will come to
see my art in my studio and i'd be like
let me show you this other thing and by
the time i'd
done my fifth tour on a friday i'd be
like crying
i'd be like this is where the music
studio is
and we're gonna build the observatory
you know i was like so
worn out by like being the showman
of like and this is what we're gonna do
here and we're gonna do a
a gap year a post high school and a post
college gap year and then we're gonna
raise funds to do
do more like kids programs and then
we're gonna [ __ ] we're gonna get
another
you know i was like driving my and i it
was it worked
but it it got to the point where it was
like i'm gonna [ __ ] die this is not
tenable
so what we're i mean if so you're having
this dark night of the soul where you're
crying about the new art spaces as
you're giving a tour
were there any changes that really moved
the needle in the right direction for
you did you or did you just take a break
from it all
for a period of time to like get your
head screwed on what did you do
the key the key the key is the people
and so our incredible board of directors
and advisors and staff
it's all on them do you know what i mean
i'm just another little cop
in the wheel or whatever so you know
again i have to take my hat off to
gabriel and to janna
and to to tommy and who's our director
of technology and to just so
tiffany and like there's just so many
people over the years some that are
still there some that aren't there
daniel kent are who's our incredible
director of design who's so talented
i it's really just the people and
that's the whole thing the idea is great
too
but it's the people and maybe those
things combobulate because
you know if you bring a musician and
i've this happened so many times or
friends of mine who play music they
would come there for the first time or
i'd be meeting a musician and showing
them around
and they'd be like holy [ __ ] this is
this is like i've dreamed
my whole life of a place like this i
cannot believe it exists
how can i be part of this how can i help
i want a seat at the table
and so you know the way they say
like-minded people attract each other
the fact that all of these crazy
disciplines are in one building and all
of these crazy souls are
are in one building that's what creates
the gravity
you know and all you know maria and all
the [ __ ]
amazing talented magical
souls that are coming and going
inside of this like vessel the building
is nothing it's a [ __ ] bunch of
bricks it's [ __ ]
without those people we're gonna come
back to maria
because there's a question i want to ask
you that that she actually suggested i
don't think she would mind me saying
that
but first we're going to get to that but
first
i want to try to connect some dots and
flesh out some of your journey so you
mentioned early in this conversation
you're hustling you're giving away art
for free you're like a thousand forget a
thousand five hundred
no no to five hundred okay take it for
free you know
you get from that point and in passing
you mentioned something that i think is
worth noting and that is
collectors or i'm not sure what you
would call them patrons
customers buying artwork in many cases
for
hundreds of thousands of dollars apiece
what were some of the
the decisions or the influences
that helped you to go from where you
were to where you
are in terms of commercial viability
right because it's
it seems like you know you've used the
word untenable a few times in this
conversation but you got to a point
where it was very
tenable like if you wanted to make
really good art and sell it for
what for a lot of artists would just be
a tremendous unthinkable
sum of money you can what were some of
the things that happened or that you did
to get from where you were to where you
are i
i think it's accumulative i think it's
it's it's so many many little things
because you know i remember when i first
sold a picture or whatever for
you know a thousand or five thousand or
ten thousand or maybe even 25 000
and i was like holy [ __ ] i just got
twenty five thousand dollars we're going
to sizzle it [ __ ] this [ __ ] is
crazy
like i can't believe how lucky i am
i just made some [ __ ] and people paid me
for it
um that being said
you know that it's like relative
now i sell something for 25 000 and it
doesn't even move the needle because i
have a big big studio and operation
and crazy projects i'm working on
but i would say it happened over you
know 25 years
a little bit at a time and at the end of
the day i think it's the work you know i
try to ask myself
three questions like can i live with it
well i go to sleep next to it each night
you're talking about a piece of work a
project a workbook yeah like can i just
live with it
can my kids live with it now i don't
have any yet but if i did
and how will i feel about it in a
hundred years
like will it still make sense to me in a
system of objects or in a system of
ideas and so i honestly
think that the work just the the work is
the work like if you tear away all the
writing about the work and all the
[ __ ]
or all of it and you just literally are
left with the thing
will that tell a story and will that
move someone
to maybe change their aperture or the
way they see the world
it happens over just a very very very
long
time you learn from each thing you do
it's like the way like what is it called
lidar works right with cars
right like it's learning it's like or an
ai is learning you're
that's how art really works right you
just keep learning
now for a lot of people the majority of
artists so they never get to
maybe these uh phase shifts
where even in 20 years 30 years they're
able to
command attention that i guess then
translates into
and i'm not going to obsess on these
prices i'm just using it as a proxy for
the work that you've done and decisions
so i do want to ask and i'm going to ask
about the
psycho geographies or psycho geographic
sketches in a second because i want you
to describe
them for people actually let's just
let's just start there and then then
i'll go to the next question but
could you describe because they are
unlike anything i have
ever seen anywhere i mean they are there
is nothing that i can think of that is
remotely
similar and you might have some type of
reference but i don't
can you describe what these as one
example
of the type of work that you do what do
these look like
if somebody were to walk into your
studio and behold these things
what do they look like well
we're talking specifically about the
psycho geographies yeah
they are they're meant to be
this installation that's taking me i
don't know how long until i finish it 10
or 15 years
of about 120 humans
that are kind of like if you think about
the terracotta warriors
they're meant to be this group of
together and they're kind of like uh
i kind of think of them as consciousness
or something or of uh
yeah if you're taking if i took your
brain and
smashed it together and
made a map of everything inside of it
that you could read through images
that's what they are so you know often
within a psychogeography you'll have
tens of thousands of
images that i'm finding from 100 years
worth of books and magazines
mixed in with paintings and drawings on
the layers of glass
so so describe the glass for a second
just so people can
paint a mental picture based on my
recollection and please correct me if
i'm wrong i'm just going to use a
an analogy here for anyone who's a star
wars nerd or at least
saw return of the jedi as an example
han solo frozen if you were to take
something like
that stand it up so that han solo is
standing on his feet per se but
suspended in the amber and then
slice that into and convert it into
multiple layers of glass and take like
the
culture and consciousness of han solo
and sort of use it to
replace the imprint of his body with
the constituent parts of that i know
this might sound strange but that's kind
of the visual
in my mind as i recall it but could you
maybe just describe the form factor and
how much it weighs what the size is like
sure i mean one one way i try to
describe it like if i'm trying to
describe it to a young person is
i just make window sandwiches i just
take a piece of glass
right i just take like a window piece of
glass and i draw on it
and i cut up my homework let's say i cut
up an encyclopedia
and i glue little pieces uh a little
human with a head of an elephant
you know next to an amethyst crystal
next to like a piece of uh architecture
you know from baja whatever i'm just
like rambling but my point is i'm
cutting up little pieces
of paper and drawings and i'm putting
them on the layer of glass
and then i add another piece of glass on
top and i do that again
but with in relationship to what i did
before and then again
and again and again and the next thing
you know you have 30 windows
on top of each other and all the
drawings mark making and all of the
pieces of paper and collage
on every single layer in concert
together
make up a psychogeography or tell a
story
and then i glue them together with a
glue that has the same refractive index
and
and the psychogeographies that you're
discussing or we're discussing are about
3 000
pounds uh each so
and and i've made works that are up to
like
modulated in 24 000 pounds or whatnot
and it's as you would expect coming out
of your brain
and hands and work it's
trippy when you look at these because
the experience changes depending on
where you are situated and looking
at the piece of art right i mean if
you're standing on the sides
is quite a different experience i mean
it's almost a vanishing act
compared to looking at it from other
perspectives and then there is
the looking at it from 20 feet away
where you think it's quite one thing
or resembles a melting person or any
number of different
the forest or stair steps within a human
body and then you get really close and
you have the micro versus the macro
experience which is
yet again something completely different
at least to the beholder how did that
start
how did the psycho geography start well
i mean
i guess i should just go backwards a
little bit with the work i don't know
you mean like how did i start making
work in layers or just the sykes
whichever one you would like to tackle i
don't mean to fixate on this as
the exclusive representation of your
work i know you've done a huge
wide spectrum of work i just think it's
helpful since we're having a
conversation with an artist for the
listeners
who are just hearing this to kind of
paint a picture of
of one example so it could be layered
art uh if that precedes
the psycho geographies and let's go with
which whichever you like
oh yeah well yeah and then we should i
mean my the newest one now you haven't
seen i don't know if you saw the
politics of eternity finished
that's a cool one but i mean really all
this was experimentation action
and and you know i was making collages
i always loved collage i always loved
again kind of what we were talking about
how do you not have system overload
maybe one of the ways i deal with the
system overload
is i love amalgamations and i love
bringing things together and pioneer
works as that with people right
but with artwork you know i used to or
still love to make
paintings and collages and drawings and
things out of rocks i'm constantly
putting disparate things together and
very much interested in
the relationships between those pieces
and i was making a collage
many years ago out of pages of a
dictionary that i was ripping up an
agnes martin
like it was an artist's grid of
dictionary pages and i started pouring
resin on the
thing and i saw an optical quality and b
got stuck and poured more resin and then
i
decided to make these sort of boxes of
resin joseph cornell
inspired i love joseph cornell like
boxes with objects and i started drawing
in layers of resin and then i took the i
saw something that looked almost
biological and i took the objects
out and i started just making these like
dendrite drawings
almost invented specimens and i got
obsessed and
i did that for some time and created
a lots of botanical looking drawings and
layers of resin and eventually i tried
drawing a human
in the layers of resin and i was
starting to get shows
and i couldn't the resin was going to
kill me
so i switched over to glass the residue
is going to kill you just because it's
is it toxic i don't know anything about
resin
yeah it's toxic and i was scaling the
work and i was
in masks all the time and it wasn't a
fun way to work
but i was actually developing a language
that i was really connecting to
and so i switched over to the layers of
glass and that
allowed me to change my mind and edit
and go back and forth because with the
resin i could only go backwards i could
never
change my mind so it was really a series
of accidents and
the psycho geography is really you know
i'm not even one i don't think that
really connects
so much to figurative art so it's weird
that i've spent a decade on a project
like that um but at the end of the day
i'm just trying
i feel like i'm trying to make maps of
consciousness i'm trying to make things
that like
a [ __ ] meteor hits the earth and
you know maybe one of these things is
left un you know you
dig it out of the dirt this 3 000 pound
glass block and it could
really almost like a microscope slide
like the dna of our species can be told
through images and through media that's
been
found and trapped and preserved and so
like
frozen movies they tell stories
through collections of ideas
i dig it and i dig it i you must have
because you are a very good teacher and
explainer of things and you mentioned
earlier the window sandwiches and
speaking to younger people
what do you think are some of the common
mistakes
that aspiring artists make right let's
just assume they have
some talent of some type and they have
some passion
let's let's assume those two things just
to try to constrain it
what are some of the mistakes that that
you see
aspiring artists or up-and-coming
artists making
well i don't know maybe maybe too much
looking at what the people around them
are doing opposed to
finding their voice through their
experience and through their lens of
life and i think that might happen in
art schools and
or getting too obsessed with one
period in art history that moves them
and then sort of trying to
emulate or build off of it too much
opposed to again
finding out what is in the bottom of
their brains
um that might be one thing um i mean
something also i mean
and also just knowing that it's not
a job it's like if if you think you can
stop doing it to do something else maybe
stop like
there's nothing else you can do never
[ __ ] giving up basically just like
and
always pushing and pushing and trying
and not giving a [ __ ] about what comes
out at the other end
really but more about learning from the
process of
making the thing how much of that is
dependent on being
willing or even embracing of living
a very simple life right because i would
imagine there
are some people out there who would say
i'd love to do that but at the end of
the day i gotta pay my rent i gotta
have x y and z shoes like you know i
can't live on ramen every
day etc is that a piece of it or am i
just
no yeah you of course gotta be able to
die for it
quite literally in a way you gotta just
be like this is the thing
you know and i've done that with the
works i mean the last work i finished
the politics of eternity which is only
the third large work
narrative work you know it took me a
couple of years
and i almost bankrupted my studio to
make it and i do that constantly
i'm like i don't give a [ __ ] about
anything but making the thing
what would happen if it bankrupted your
studio what would you
how would you feel and what would you do
would it just be destiny and then you'd
figure become a short order cook or what
would what would happen
i'd probably go like i don't know become
like yeah go live in a [ __ ]
tropic somewhere and live off of
coconuts
seriously i'm always like you know if it
were anyone else i'd be like ha ha ha i
mean i am laughing but
i'm laughing in part because i can
totally [ __ ] imagine it
yeah i would be so confirmed in fact
that that life calls me
constantly but i try to do these really
like the new piece the politics of
eternity was really cool it's got like a
whole
narrative where i'm trying to depict the
past and the future simultaneously
and in the future there is uh
astronauts inhabiting the world if you
will
in the past where there would be
astronauts
there's animal-headed humans if that
makes sense to you
and everything is mirrored so
in the future they're building a rocket
on the top of a mountain and in the same
place in the past
they're building a totemic antenna to
the gods
so everything is mirrored you know
the tunnels in the future are straight
and modern and in the past organic
and in the future there's the same tree
that's growing in the future is growing
in the same place in the past
or where there's a particle accelerator
in the future there's a cave of minerals
in the past or where there's like a
group sisyphus moment
in the past underneath the ocean where
the animal-headed humans are pushing a
boulder
to capture a sea monster in a cave that
same moment's happening in the same
place
underneath the ocean in the future but
it's astronauts
pushing a machine to capture data
that's coming out of the sea and where
the moon is
in the future there's the sun in the
past and you've got mars
right in the middle splitting the worlds
and the future in the past are also
depicted by waterfalls falling in to the
present simultaneously
where there's uh you know these weird uh
narratives on on the sea and there's a
super tanker
sinking which is connected to another
project and there's there's uh
animals coming out of the super tanker
as an allegory to the ark
so i just want to pause for a second and
tell people
go to dustinyellen.com or at
dustinyellen on instagram and this will
make a lot more sense
not that it doesn't make sense but they
might think to themselves holy [ __ ] this
guy's done a lot of acid which is also
true
but it's a lot easier to absorb
visually in a sense although i like the
description i want to harken back to
something you said which was you have to
be willing to die for it and you talked
about death for a moment and that
actually relates to the question
that maria popova for people who don't
know who that is she's the most
prolific writer imaginable
very talented brainpickings.org she
suggested that
i perhaps explore the death of your
mentor or one of your mentors i don't
have context for this question so i
please tell me if i'm barking up the
wrong tree but
does that question bring anything to the
surface for you it seemed like
this was something worth plumbing the
depths of a bit
yeah well i mean i mean i'm an old man
now i've lost a lot of people but when i
was young
young 25 i lost my best friend and who
was like
my mentor and teacher was a teacher and
i think that completely affected
me for the rest of my life um and since
then i've lost a lot of people including
one of my mentors
who was older than me and i think when i
was young i was always obsessed with
death and i think i probably still
am because i think of you know i don't
know how time works i think it maybe
is that the past and the present and the
future
exists simultaneously and somehow you
can access it
and i'm not sure that when the body dies
or or we we die here
that it's all gone i'm very much an
optimist and think that maybe there's
some semblance of it that we can still
tap into because
energy cannot be destroyed i don't know
how it works
i definitely have been obsessed with it
always and still
am and again back to that idea of
over-system overload well if i think
about
right now how many summers left do i
have
you know call it 50 for the sake of the
conversation you too you you and i have
let's say 50 summers left
right well [ __ ] 50 summers is like lunch
for sure you know it's so fast it's so
quick and finite and and so i don't know
if that
affects my relationship to death even
though i think it
might be infinite and that somehow i
don't know how it really works but but
yeah
death has really informed maybe
losing you know someone the closest
person to me at such a young age i think
really
it uh changed the way i see the world
completely does that obsessing over
death and i'm asking as someone who
really in the last few months has been
thinking about death almost
constantly i'm curious to know what
form that obsession has taken in other
words
is it heavy and foreboding
does it lead to a depressive feeling
is it just a kind of snap of the fingers
and kicking the ass
like hey homie let's get moving you
don't have that much time so let's use
this
as best we can what is the sort of
emotional tenor of that obsessing over
death
i think it's probably the latter's is
like look
the rest of your life is [ __ ] almost
over
so you better get into it now
you know what i mean like this is it
there is
nothing else but to this [ __ ] minute
this hour
and i have a hard time i think thinking
about
forever or like for the rest of my life
and and i think there's
it's posited some of some challenges
probably
in like maybe why i haven't started a
family yet or
maybe i need to start a family right
away or making decisions
in interpersonal relationships i think
it's challenged me
because i'm like this is it like right
now i could
literally be gone in 12 hours
it's completely plausible and therefore
i want to open up the aperture and maybe
that's through meditation or maybe
that's just through listening and being
quiet but i want to open up the aperture
as much as possible
all of the time and feel as much as
possible all of the time
because the way that i feel right now
may
could be gone or completely change so
if we're looking at living your best
life i sort of dropped this in the
beginning this is going to seem like a
very strange segue
but from the sort of sublime to the
maybe ridiculous how did you end up
dancing in a jay-z
video is that even a real thing
i literally i mean i did it's true that
i used to break dance
on venice boardwalk like when we were
living there for a heartbeat and i would
[ __ ] yeah i remember like moving up
starting on cardboard
and then like people would give me like
15 bucks over the few hours and then
like i moved up to linoleum
which i thought was cool i don't know
video happened i mean he's cool i'd like
to actually have a coffee with him at
some point
so hold on so do you literally just not
have a recollection of how you got
filmed or were you
like how does that happen i actually
don't know yeah i got a phone call
they're like show up at this place i
didn't know what the [ __ ] i was doing oh
god i feel like there's so many
so many directions we could take that
let me ask you this this is
um a question that is sometimes a dead
end it's not always a great question but
i'll try it and it is
if you could put anything on a gigantic
billboard
metaphorically speaking right to get a
message an image a question a word
whatever
out to billions of people what might it
be
you mean an image or a word or something
to billions of people anything at all
non-commercial
hopefully yeah yeah no i would just want
to try to get everybody to love each
other
like get everyone to be a little bit
more tolerant
a little bit more open a little you know
f scott fitzgerald said that a
first-rate intelligence is the ability
to hold two opposing ideas in the mind
simultaneously and still
retain the ability to function so that
if we could just
somehow accept our differences as the
the great glue that creates the
complexity
and miracle of what we experience
so i mean that would be the thing i
would try to somehow portray is to say
that look
all of us every single one of us is
experiencing
the same thing differently and we're all
made of the same
stuff and we're all sharing the same
stuff so why on earth are we
you know deploying capital at such a
scale to defense opposed to
education or healthcare why are why you
know why is our
why is the world look the way it does
when really it could be so
so incredibly dreamy if we all just
decided together to do that you
mentioned
earlier the tanker and he said that
connects to another project
and i remember you sharing a couple
of slides i think was on a laptop
related to this
but can you describe this other tanker
project and just tell people what the
vision and or the status
is of this project lest they think it's
all about window sandwiches
although that i love love love love
those uh that work what is the other
tanker project
a super tanker moves fossil fuels around
and i've been obsessed with this thing
for years and now it's got a little bit
of movement but just this
idea of how do you how do you bring
awareness
to getting away from fossil fuels and
i'm working on a project called the
bridge because it's a bridge from the
past to the future of how we
use and think about energy where i'm
taking a super tanker which is a boat
that moves oil around
and it started to be like 1200 feet it's
not as big anymore but it'll still be
the largest lift
i think in history where we're taking a
super tanker and
literally in one moment we're pulling it
up
and putting it on its nose basically
like almost like a
like a monument to the end of fossil
fuels and we're coating it
so that safely let's say a million or a
million and a half visitors
can go take elevators through the boat
up to the top of it and then get to an
observation deck which
is made of the bridge which is where you
used to control the ship from hence the
name the bridge also
double name and uh through the
experience of visiting
this monument you'll learn about uh the
history of energy
and potentially the future of how we can
responsibly shepherd in
a cleaner safer way to power the earth
so yeah so that's the bridge i'm
basically just putting a super tanker on
his nose
um again love that's what probably you
know i love fitzgerald pulling a boat
over a mountain i'm i'm now trying to
take a boat
the size of a building and put it on his
nose so it's like a statue of liberty
with the liberty being freedom from
fossil fuels or at least that's the
size of the statue of liberty and yes
it's uh
it's a monument to the end of fossil
fuels it's like a monument
look we can power the earth with water
and with sun
and with you know various other
technologies if we can
if we can scale them where might the
bridge be
right i can't say i can't say all right
we'll keep it under wraps for
now i'm using the royal wii since i have
no [ __ ] idea but tbd
this is a really cool project i'm
working with you know vrk ingles who's
an amazing architect and i'm working
with arab engineering and i'm working
with all these cool people who are
helping me to realize this dream
that's incredible just a few more things
and uh this has been so much fun so i'm
looking at a quote from
the creativeindependent.com and the
paragraph
is attributed to you i believe and
here's how it reads but i try to wake up
every day with this mantra or idea that
i've done
nothing you know i've accomplished
nothing i've done nothing and the page
is white
therefore therefore is my words what's
possible what can be invented now
is that something that you constantly
remind yourself of
is that still the case or is that
intermittent how do you think about
the i've done nothing
blank slate is that accurate absolutely
i feel that every day
because it's true i mean
until we've come to a place where
there's more harmony and more equality
uh
and more justice and more thoughtfulness
uh on our planet that we share
i certainly feel like i've done nothing
i mean i mean because if anything is
possible
then think about how much we can do
together then what i've done
has in the past and if the past is no
longer
now then therefore i've done nothing
so i i kind of feel that way all the
time do you find
that intimidating overwhelming
or invigorating or something else right
cause i could imagine some people would
be so crushed under the
formidable nature of that type of what
they might view as a burden or
obligation that they just would be
paralyzed
no i i i mean i guess i probably have
semblances of all of those feelings but
if anything
i feel the wonder and possibility
of what we can make as a species
together or
as an individual that it's all possible
right that
it's like if i look at a white piece of
paper and then four hours later there's
a drawing there
there was nothing and now there's
something and this idea between
nothing and something is really
interesting because
if you look at cities and technologies
and all of it there was nothing
and then there was something and so
we really do have that capacity to
create absolutely anything
all of the time dustin i think that is a
great place for me to stop my
inquisition of questions
so fun to reconnect people can find you
on instagram
dustin yellen last name y-e-l-l-i-n
dustin yellen.com pioneerworks.org i
highly recommend people check out all of
those
and of course we'll link to everything
we've talked about the movies the books
everything else
in the show notes for people so anything
else that you'd like to say before we
close up shop on this
first conversation on the podcast well i
wouldn't even know where to i mean
read some poetry think of this whole
thing as a poem
you know realize that that
all of our you know i guess if
if people could just [ __ ] come
together and the
injustices and the incomprehensible
horrors that this species uh has
created with some of also the great
things on the planet in the past
like let the past let us learn from it
but know that going forward we really
if we choose to can build the world that
everyone wants to live in
together uh you know in a way that is
equal
and just and we can all sort of
support and love each other to keep
[ __ ]
inventing the dream i like that
it's inventing the dream it's not
finding the dream right because you can
each day like you said choose to create
something from nothing
and uh it certainly helps when you have
the right people at the table
as you put it which i think is a
beautiful metaphor and to do that you
have to sometimes go out and invite
those people find those people which is
i think a common thread throughout a lot
of the adventures that you've had
oh i'm the weird guy who in new york
city even going down the street i'm
saying hello to everybody and they're
like looking at me like what's wrong
with him
well dustin thank you so much for taking
the time this has been a lot of fun
for me and i've learned a lot so i
really do appreciate it
and for people listening as always
i will link to all the resources and
there will be a transcript and all sorts
of things which you can find at tim.blog
forward slash podcast just search for
dustin
or dustin yellen or yellen y-e-l-l-i-n
and until next time be safe thanks for
tuning in
and see what you can do at this empty
table of life
and good luck
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the uh the world of the esoteric as i do
it could include favorite articles that
i've read
and that i've shared with my close
friends for instance
and it's very short it's just a little
tiny bite
of goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's four
hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
expressvpn i've been using expressvpn
since the summer of 2019.
it is a super simple and reliable way to
make sure that my data
are secure and encrypted without slowing
my internet speed so for instance i use
public wi-fi all over the place
might be at a starbucks it could be at a
restaurant sitting outside somewhere to
work i
travel all the time and expressvpn is an
easy way to make sure that i am not
getting
my packets and data sniffed and
viewed by other people all you need to
do is download the expressvpn app on
your computer or smartphone and then use
the internet
as you normally would you click one
button in the expressvpn app
to secure 100 of your network data of
the many vpn solutions out there
expressvpn is one of the best on the
market it's
super easy super simple and i use it
personally
in addition to protecting your data you
can also use a vpn to unlock movies and
shows that are only available in other
countries
so you can unlock content this is
actually a very very
good use case and super helpful
expressvpn hides your ip address and
lets you control
where you want sites to think you're
located you can choose from almost
100 different countries so just think
about all the netflix
libraries that you can go through if you
love anime use expressvpn to access
japanese netflix for instance and be
spirited away one of my favorite movies
by the way spirited away
but it's not just netflix expressvpn
works with any streaming service hulu
bbc iplayer youtube
you name it there's never any buffering
or lag and you can stream in hd with no
problem
expressvpn is also compatible with all
of your devices phones media consoles
smart tvs and so on so you can watch
what you want on the go or on a big
screen wherever you happen to be
so consider protecting yourself with the
vpn that i use and trust
visit expressvpn.com tim
and get an extra three months free on a
one year package
that's expressvpn.com
tim one more time check out
expressvpn.com
tim to learn more this episode is
brought to you by
xero zero the world's most popular
fasting app
long-term listeners will know that i
take fasting very seriously i've studied
it
i've practiced it i do three day fasts i
do seven
to ten day fasts every year and i take
it
super seriously the science i think is
in
there is increasingly more and more
literature pointing out the many
benefits
of doing even short periods of fasting
and now xero
is helping millions of users around the
world unlock healthier
longer lives by harnessing the power of
fasting it's been downloaded millions of
times like i mentioned
4.9 out of 5 stars on the apple app
store as an example with more than
200 000 ratings probably more than 300
000 ratings at this point
and up to this point in time for me
for years when i've had questions for
instance
do artificial sweeteners count can i
consume those even though perhaps they
might spike insulin levels a little bit
what about heavy cream and coffee if i
remain ketogenic
and i'm not adding any glucose to
my diet so to speak is that okay what
about the difference between say a 16
hour fast versus 72 hour versus
seven day what do we actually know how
much of this is just old wives tales
versus real
science that we can point to i would
always call or text
or email dr peter attita peter tia my
friend he's been on the podcast many
times
and he is now zero's chief medical
officer so he has an entire library of q
as and questions
and advice all the kind of stuff that i
couldn't give anyone else access to
people now have access
to which is incredible so kevin rose my
buddy created this app initially in 2016
and it's turned into an incredible
community and an incredible collection
of how-to and tracking capabilities so
whether you've been fasting for years or
just getting started xero equips you
with exclusive videos
from people like peter attila
personalized fasting plans and advanced
health data to keep you on track
listeners of this podcast that's you
guys can get 30
off a one year zero plus subscription
which gets you all sorts of goodies so i
would highly recommend checking it out
get a full
year's access to content and fasting
plans developed by the medical experts i
trust
like dr peter tia and save twenty
dollars just visit
zerofasting.com tim to get your
exclusive discount
that's zerofasting.com
tim and your discount will be
automatically applied
one last time zerofasting.com
you